beaucoup de gens sont inquiets au
mexique et ils le sont plus lorsque la
maladie les oblige à s'approcher des
hôpitaux ou à y entrer officiellement
tout est sous contrôle même si le pic de
l'épidémie n'a pas encore été atteint et
si elle frappe encore plus la région de
la capitale avec ses 22 millions
d'habitants
les tests manquer les familles craignent
la contagion
comme cet homme dont la mère d'une
famille de huit est à l'hôpital il est
sûr que les chiffres sont sous-estimés
[Musique]
ouvert il n'y a qu'à voir toutes ces
ambulances ça ne va pas bien dit il et
le trafic d'ambulances est
particulièrement chargé près des
résidences pour personnes âgées comme
ici à monterrey dans le nord
autre signe qui ne trompe pas les
crématoriums qui ont du mal à suivre
comme celui de sochi milk au sud de
mexico
malgré ça le gouvernement mexicain est
prêt à rouvrir le pays le président
lopez obrador appelle ça la nouvelle
normalité
ce sera progressif dès le 18 mai pour
les région peu touchée et ensuite 1er
juin mais avec des limites selon les
couleurs du vert au rouge activités
prioritaires la construction les mines
et les industries du transport
non cela se fera de façon volontaire du
président rien par la force et tout par
la raison et le droit il faudra
surmonter l'inquiétude des travailleurs
du secteur automobile près de la
frontière
certaines usines ont été touchées par la
maladie ont dû fermer les travailleurs
protestent parce qu'ils se sentent mal
protégé mais en même temps il aimerait
bien reprendre le travail
la situation économique du mexique et
critique depuis plus d'un an et le
premier trimestre a été catastrophique
jean michel leprince radio canada mon
frère